all right a really bizarre story out of
Illinois tonight where a satanic temple
installed a display in the Illinois
Capitol next to a nativity scene with
the group saying that it is an effort to
commemorate their quote satanic values
can't believe this anyway it's the
fourth year this satanic group has
installed the display which features a
crocheted snake among other satanic
imagery meanwhile up in Boston a member
of the Dedham Human Rights Commission
has now resigned following an unhinged
diatribe on Facebook mocking Christians
amid a local controversy surrounding the
Banning of Christmas trees at a local
library now the woman who has been
identified as Diane loud wrote in part
quote is this what you think uh your
magic Sky daddy wants where in the Bible
was this again and she has now resigned
from her position but thankfully most
common sense American us appreciate the
Christmas season and the values that
bring us together including the
importance of prayer and the power of
Faith by the way both are major themes
and a brand new book from our very own
Harris Faulkner entitled Faith still
moves mountains it's a great book
debuting number one on the New York
Times list Harris joins us now how are
you Harris
fantastic Sean thank you so very much uh
for having me on tonight and as you were
telling those stories all I can think
about is the fact that the mountain that
needs to be moved right now is just this
idea that Christians and Jews can be
pushed aside by anything that people
would do you know the woman in Dedham
Massachusetts was really offensive and I
don't just hold her accountable in all
of this getting angry over the fact that
the library wanted to have a Christmas
tree in her small town but what about
the Town Council what about the town of
Dedham that that put out this statement
that said she quit why didn't they push
her out she was appointed she said some
really horrible things about the
librarian who'd been there for 28 years
who said hey we missed the Christmas
tree why can't we bring it back by the
way the town had appointed her to the
Council of Human Rights Commission
although she attacked this with no
Humanity in her heart she went after
Christians you you were right she she
called it the the magic skydaddy which
is kind of an old school term by
atheists
um you just look at this and you wonder
well is this right on time we're
supposed to pull together as people of
Faith this time of the year this is like
in the Book of Job when Satan actually
has to show that job is strong in his
faith no matter his circumstances I
think we can all do that no matter what
these people are doing with their hate
and any of it we can still be strong
it's time to be bold right now you know
it's amazing because Satanism is all
about Darkness it's all about evil your
book is just the opposite where Faith
moves mountains uh and about you know
even even things as simple as love God
with all your heart mind body and soul
and your neighbor as yourself uh very
different messages but what is their
argument that this is
um their religion Satanism evil is their
religion
you know what's so interesting so when
you look at that situation because I was
talking about the Christmas tree at the
library in Massachusetts which is just
plain silliness because they're going to
do it now but with the satanic temple in
in Illinois their Minister was saying
that it's not that they're devil
worshipers but the very word Satan in
Hebrew means adversary and in the
Christian Book of Job when you look at
it it's more than that it is the
opposition to God so they know who they
are they know what they stand for and
they have put up their display next to
the symbols of Christmas and the menorah
for Hanukkah that's coming up and is
this an answer back in some sort is the
question that you're asking Sean but we
don't need an answer back what we need
is for people to lean into their faith
so that there is an automatic
spiritual warfare going on there that
has an impenetrable weapon and that is
the power of prayer it is that something
kindness it is powerful you said this is
the assignment of your life I recommend
everybody Faith still moves mountains
number one best-selling book uh Harris a
good friend great to see you thanks for
sharing that with us we appreciate it